aucun élève à l'horizon ce mercredi
matin au collège intercommunal Philippe
de champEn du Ménil Saint-Denis et pour
cause enseignants et parents d'élèves
organiser une opération collège mort en
réponse à la suppression de deux classes
au sein de l'établissement dès la
rentrée prochaine depuis plusieurs
années et en particulier cette année on
réduit nos moyens pour enseigner et ce
qui va se traduire l'année prochaine par
la fermeture de deux classes et ce qui
va monter nos effectifs à 28 à 30 élèves
par classe on n même plus là pour nos
salaires ou nos conditions de travail on
est là juste pour pouvoir enseigner dans
de bonnes conditions faire notre travail
correctement et s'occuper correctement
des élèves et des enfants qu'on nous
confie aujourd'hui le collège Philippe
de Champaigne est un établissement
particulier 30 % des élèves accueillis
ont des besoins spécifiques liés à des
handicaps ou appartenants à des zones
d'éducation prioritaire pour les parents
d'élèves l'augmentation des effectifs
dans les classes dégraderait les
conditions de travail moi j'ai par
exemple j'ai posé la question à mon fils
dit mais si tu vous retrouvez à 30 par
classe qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça va
te faire son questionnement ça a été
mais on va être trop nombreux comment on
va faire pour travailler en fait ça va
être trop bruillant un sentiment que
partagent les maires des communes de la
verrière et du Menil Saint-Denis venu
apporter leur soutien aux manifestants
tout comme le député William Martinet
moi je suis en désaccord avec cette
logique comptable au sein de l'éducation
nationale qui est de dire il faut
supprimer des postes il faut fermer des
classes pour faire des économies et que
la priorité ça devrait être l'intérêt
des élèves si on veut que le collège
reste attractif il faut assumer de
conserver des moyens reçu par l'Académie
en janvier dernier prof professeurs et
parents d'élèves n'avaient pas été
satisfaits des réponses données d'autres
opérations comme celle-ci pourraient
être organisées après les vacances
scolaires